There are hundreds of former prosecutors who
are now asserting that Donald Trump obstructed
justice, that he committed the crime of obstruction
of justice.
And we've been talking about this for some
time now.
It's been several weeks since the bar letter
and eventually the redacted Muller report.
Uh, and we've been talking about the fact
that Robert Mueller didn't decide about indicting
Donald Trump for obstruction of justice.
Trump and William Barr and others have framed
Robert Mueller's decision not to indict for
obstruction of evidence, for obstruction of
justice as evidence of exoneration.
But Robert Muller actually makes it really,
really clear, uh, in the, uh, report that
he is not exonerating Trump, that he's unable
to exonerate Trump the terms substantial evidence
of obstruction by Donald Trump is used in
Mueller's report.
But what Muller does say is that for political
reasons, including that indicting a sitting
president would hamper their ability to carry
out the task of being president of the United
States molar, was going to leave the decision
about indictment to the attorney general who
of course was selected by Trump and immediately
said, oh yeah, we're not inditing Trump.
But Robert Mueller's decision not to indict
Trump was a political decision.
It's not a legal decision based on the evidence.
And case in point, there are now more than
370 former federal prosecutors who have worked
for both Republican and Democratic presidents
who have signed their names to a statement
that politics aside, meaning like if you forget
for a second that we're talking about a sitting
president.
If you look at Trump, the person Trump, the
man, uh, Trump homo sapiens, the evidence
against Trump for obstruction would lead to
an indictment for any other member of Homo
sapiens who did the stuff that Donald Trump
did.
Trump's attorney general.
William Barr has been insisting that the evidence
doesn't suggest indictment against Trump,
but more than 370 federal prosecutors who
have worked for Republicans who over for Democrats,
but more importantly are not currently working
for Donald Trump.
Disagree.
They're not saying to be very clear, Trump
would be found guilty of obstruction of justice.
They are federal prosecutors.
They understand that Trump would get his day
in court and that there would be a trial and
maybe Trump would be found guilty and maybe
he wouldn't.
With the 370 federal prosecutors are saying
is that Trump would be indicted on the basis
of the evidence and then it would go to trial
and Trump could defend himself and mount the
strongest legal defense possible based on
the evidence that the indictment should have
taken place.
Uh, there's a Twitter user, Yammer jaw who
has been doing some really great visualizations
of the Mueller report and actually did one
for obstruction.
Obstruction has three elements, was the act
obstructive was their corrupt intent, meaning
that the person doing the obstructive act
knew that they were acting improperly in order
to obstruct.
And third, was the person aware that there
was something to obstruct?
In other words, were they aware that in this
case there was an investigation whereby the
actions would be considered obstructive of
it.
There are 14 possible obstructive actions
by Donald Trump and we have them up on the
screen for our visual audience and molar found
that in aid of those 14 Donald Trump's actions
met all three elements of obstruction.
Those eight are telling Jim, call me to let
Michael Flynn off the hook firing James Comey
trying to fire Robert Mueller, trying to focus
the molar pro boldly on future elections instead
on what Trump did, which is laughable.
Trying to have Jeff sessions take over the
investigation, trying to influence Paul Manafort
dealings with Robert Mueller and publicly
attacking Michael Cohen and his family to
influence his dealings with Mueller.
Uh, and his testimony, there are eight counts
of obstruction where molar found all three
elements that are needed for obstruction to
be present.
And you have 370 former federal prosecutors
who were simply saying it's very clear.
It's very clear.
If you read the molar report, you understand
this.
Most people don't read the molar report.
So it's very good to have lots of prosecutors
signing on to this in the same way that debating
impeachment of the president and the House
of Representatives, even if they don't move
forward, would be such a great thing merely
to expose people who are either in the Fox
News Echo Chamber or who are just busy living
their lives and don't have time to read a
450 page report like people who work in this
world have the time or make the time to do
expose the reality that the whole, no collusion,
no obstruction, no indictment exoneration
narrative, uh, is, uh, public relations.
It's a managed PR campaign and we have to
do what we can to publicize the content of
the molar report period.
That's what these prosecutors are doing.
They're exactly right.
It takes only looking at the Mueller report
and at what is said in there about evidence
to make that, uh, to recognize and to understand
why it is that this is so important, good
for the prosecutors.
And hopefully more people will become aware
not of propagandized, uh, opinions about the
report, but simply what is in the report because
it truly does speak for itself.